axa bonjour eric dupond moretti est venu
donc détailler les articles du projet de
loi comportant les principes de la
république alors sur quel thème at il
insisté
oui alors ce qui concerne son ministère
elle a été entendu ce matin par cette
commission qui est présidée par françois
de rugy alors il a tout d'abord en
introduction expliqué que ce texte était
essentiel porteurs de liberté je vous
propose de l'écouter ce projet pour moi
comme pour le président de la république
et comme pour le gouvernement bien sûr
est un texte essentiel
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire que
c'était un texte de liberté on ce que de
façon presque tautologique rappeler ce
que sont les valeurs de la république
c'est rappeler ce qu'est la liberté et
il est essentiel pour nous de nous
prémunir des dérives séparatistes d'où
qu'elles viennent d'ailleurs qui
menacent la nation et la république
essentiel de réaffirmer que tous les
français de kiel viennent quel que soit
le dieu qu'il prie ou qu'il ne prit pas
font avant tout partie d'une communauté
la communauté nationale est essentielle
enfin parce que ce texte a pour ambition
de renforcer les principes qui fondent
notre état de droit afin de lutter
efficacement contre eux
toutes les idéologies qui le menacent et
c'est parce que les enjeux de ce texte
sont si grands qu'une commission a été
spécialement constituée pour l'après ont
déjà souligné ici devant vous
l'importance que revêt bien sûr le débat
parlementaire on regarde de l'objet de
ce projet de loi parce qu'il touche à ce
qui fait le pacte républicain
alors il a évoqué tout d'abord l'article
3 sur les propos haineux qu'ils soient
publics ou en ligne et bien les
contrevenants vont s'exposer à être
inscrits automatiquement au pij est le
fichier judiciaire national sur les
infractions à caractère terroriste et
puis il a présenté l'article iv il crée
un nouveau délit
ce sera celui d'exercer une menace une
intimidation envers un agent du service
public pour qu'il modifie justement sa
mission de service public ça peut être
par exemple un enseignant auquel un
élève demanderait de modifier son cours
ou encore un médecin qui ne pourraient
examiner une femme parce que c'est un
homme
ceci sous l' influence de son mari est
alors le contrevenant s'expose à une
sanction qui pourrait être 5 ans de
prison et 75000 euros d'amendé article
18 quant à lui créé un délit une
nouvelle fois de mise en danger
intentionnelle de la vie d'autrui en
diffusant des informations familiale
privée ou encore professionnels
on pense bien entendu à ce qui est
arrivé à l'enseignant samuel pâtir
puisque des informations sur son lieu de
travail avait été divulguée quant à
l'article 20 il vise la comparution
immédiate d'auteur de tels faits voici
pour l'intervention d'eric
dupond-moretti ce matin sachant que
marlène schiappa vient de terminer la
sienne sur les articles relevant de son
ministère
merci beaucoup qu'elle sape est
meilleure pour tous ces précisions
depuis l'assemblée nationale